all right let's get right into audience
questions for the week the first one
I've gotten it from a bunch of different
people since the corona virus pandemic
got going the question is is this
bitcoins big opportunity will the
coronavirus recession lead to bitcoins
huge adoption and also valuation so full
disclosure I've already said when all of
this started one of the moves I made was
I I did pick up some additional Bitcoin
and I've had some four years that I've
just been holding and my thought is
maybe it's a hedge that is not
correlated to the broader market so it's
conceivable that it's a hedge it may not
be and in fact on some days that the
stock market has been down hugely so has
Bitcoin so I have no special knowledge I
did that but I'm clueless I don't know
what I'm doing here's my thought what is
it that would have to happen with the
dollar for a lot of people to go to
Bitcoin who are not already in the space
what would have to happen to the Euro
for people to go into Bitcoin because
this really is is more a question of
currency than it is of recession and why
do I say that the reason I say that is
you get the tech adoption barriers aside
imagine that people just as easily and
of course that that it's just not going
to happen but imagine that people much
more easily could get and use Bitcoin so
that it becomes more comparable to
getting and using US dollars or a euro
or whatever your local currency is if
you get the tech barriers out of the way
people are only going to be looking to
Bitcoin as a flight to safety if their
country's currency either becomes much
more volatile so that it matches or
approximates the volatility of Bitcoin
because remember bitcoin is very
volatile and we've seen it in the last
couple of years be worth as much as
$19,000 per coin at the end of 2017
early 2018 I believe it's been all the
way down to five
that's a Forex swing US dollar of
has fluctuations but they are far
smaller than what we've seen in bitcoins
so one thing that would need to happen
if we solve the tech barriers to more
people getting involved with Bitcoin is
the volatility of Bitcoin would have to
come down while the volatility of the
dollar goes up that would be one thing
secondly there would have to be some
real evidence that aside from what your
investment choices are with dollars that
going to Bitcoin is going to be safer
over the long term than sticking with
dollars and this is more than just
volatility only if there is a signal
that the dollar will not only be
volatile but might really lose so much
value that your purchasing power will be
decreased would people be encouraged to
go and and move money to Bitcoin and in
addition to that if it's not going to be
useful for buying things that you need
particularly if the corona virus
pandemic extends and we have supply
chain interruptions that are not
currently expected and we have
difficulties obtaining certain products
simply with US dollars on websites like
Target comm and Amazon etc I don't think
that there is going to be a wholesale
move in the direction of Bitcoin my
sense is that the move to Bitcoin which
over the last couple of weeks has seen
Bitcoin ascend in value and maybe by the
time this clip publishes that will have
reversed I think that it is a fraction
of the population around the world that
has said hey if governments can be
really poor at dealing with the pandemic
maybe I shouldn't be all-in with their
currency either and I'll pick up some
Bitcoin I believe that that is the
lion's share of the move to Bitcoin that
we have seen over the last month or so
if people really were saying I've got to
get out of my state skirt my country's
currency and get over the Bitcoin you
would have seen such a larger increase
in the value of Bitcoin than the one
that we've seen so that's that's my view
volatility would
to go up drastically for
government-backed currencies down for
Bitcoin the technical barriers would
have to be solved the coronavirus
situation would really have to extend
longer than even the best models now
suggest it would and then in that case
yes maybe this will prove to be bitcoins
a big opportunity if you disagree with
me let me know that's what I'm seeing so
far